[Music]
alex is with us in houston texas hey
alex welcome to the ramsey show
hello gentlemen thank you for taking my
call sure what's up baby i'm in babysit
too and i would like your advice on
whether or not i should spend money for
a financial coach the coaching fee for
the coach i'm looking at will be 250 a
month and i bring home 2 000 a month i'm
pretty strong on the head of college
i've been listening to you guys for a
couple years now but i'm really
struggling with the 80 behavior part and
uh keeping consistency and i would like
your advice what you think i should do
no if you're making two thousand dollars
a month i would not spend 250 a month on
a coach
that's too much as a percentage of your
income have you noticed alex that your
income sucks
it does yeah i definitely
want to find a way to increase my shovel
and um you are uh
right in line with with the facebook
group i put a poll out on there and 90
92 percent gave me a no don't do it 82
maybe you need a new job doing
statistics oh my gosh
yeah what do you do what's your income
what are you what's your career i i work
in a factory a food production factory
and um
interesting part of my story i'm less
than a year fresh out of prison and i'm
just trying to rebuild my life together
and make up for some
bad decisions that i've made in the past
and
part of that is trying to find a career
where
i will be given a chance but i can also
um
be paid for my my worth like what i can
what i'm capable for and uh what would
that be
forget your record right now what would
you be pursuing if you didn't have this
pass that you knew you were gonna have
to navigate around
yeah
what would you do what would you do what
do you want to do i love working in
restaurants that's one thing but it's
not long-term and stable i really would
love to be
a real estate agent and and to sell
houses i really like working with people
um that would be something that i think
i would be good at sales in general i
think i'll be good at because i was
really good at it in the restaurant
industry yeah i made good money doing
what i did
and um i would love to go into sales so
here's the thing um we are seeing coming
out of the pandemic and i want you to
actually do some research on this i
think you'll be surprised at what you
find there are a lot of companies around
this country that are really truly
reaching out to people with a criminal
record they're non-violent and and
things of that nature and they really
have proven that they've entered into
society and they've paid their
they've paid their dues
and they're looking because we have such
a huge gap right now with 11.3 million
jobs this last job report out of july
11.3 million jobs available 8.3 million
people unemployed and i'm just telling
you you'd be surprised at some companies
that are willing to give men and women
like you a chance that's one thing i
want you just do your research and see
what's out there second thing
whether that was a a true piece of data
or not
relationships relationships
relationships people are going to see
your story
and you get to an interview process and
you tell them that you've got a record
because you're an honest guy and they
will still shoot you down
right there but the reality is is
through relationships
people that you know who know you and
know that you're a good dude and know
that you have paid your debt to society
and now you're trying to do what's right
they are going to be the key to you
getting where you want to go and i'm
going to tell you something if you want
to get into real estate
you just got to find that one or two
people who say you know what i'll be
your broker i'll put my arm around you
i'll develop you i'll pour into you i
believe in you because the reality is is
people will buy a house from somebody
that is kind that is knowledgeable and
helps them accomplish their dream of
getting that home they're not doing a
background check on you so i'm just i
wanted to just put that in your heart so
that you know you actually can get where
you want to go does does texas real
estate law prohibit a felon from getting
a real estate license
that's something i need to research um
definitely i don't think it's not sure i
don't think it does it will keep you out
of the securities business you're not
going to be a stock broker
or a financial advisor another
another realm of sales might be better
for me yeah but the but real estate uh i
most states do not uh have that as a
prohibition on a real estate license
um
and uh so how long have you been out
i've been out since october of last year
so i'm coming up on a year good for you
okay
and how old are you
28 years old okay cool
cool
well you're you're you're up for a fresh
start i love that yeah and um
you know if i'm you uh
i'm gonna move towards sales because of
some kind because you're a people person
you're articulate and you can make more
in 20 minutes in sales than you're
making now
yeah i don't know what you're selling at
this point you know in this discussion
but i i think you've got some
opportunity there uh and you know real
estate is a tougher one to get in
because it takes longer to start making
money other types of sales you can get
and you make money then the week
and real estate sometimes it often takes
six months uh you know to get the
on-ramp going
and um you don't really have that kind
of margin but no i would not spend 250
out of 2000
uh for a financial coach financial
coaching is worth every penny but you
know you can't you know you're not in a
position to afford that right now you're
not making enough money so i want to
work on the shovel size
and some other things in the process and
what we'll do is we'll put you guys put
you through financial peace university
as our guest and that'll help you with
the behavior side as well
uh but you're learning a whole lot of
new things about self-control and about
behavior and about you the guy in your
mirror in this stage of your life
you're you're coming through a whole
process there in every element of your
life so if i'm you i'm plugging into a
great church
i'm going to get some strong
uh emotionally mature uh
men in my life if i'm you that are older
than you that'll walk beside you and
coach you and give you opportunities and
connect you to their buddies and say hey
you know here's alex he needs a shot
and uh and they'll walk with you and you
can meet those kinds of men in a good
church
and uh you need those kinds of folk in
your life right now and then get in this
class but no i i'm i'm not gonna tell
you i mean we've got several thousand
ramsay trained financial coaches across
america that are worth every penny that
they charge they're wonderful they're
absolutely incredible but no i would not
tell somebody making two thousand
dollars a month to spend 250 dollars a
month on that that's not a good play
not a good play at all
there is um
something that has to happen almost in
dr john dolone's realm
when you go through something like that
to get that in your past there's the
reality that he faces of you know when
he applies he's a felon right that's
right there's a reality background check
whatever all those kind of there's a
reality there but the other thing is is
it
you you have to redefine yourself
say i am not defined by my past
i'm informed by it that's right and so
i'm not a guy i'm not a a bankruptcy i'm
a guy that filed bankruptcy 30 years ago
and it informed what i did in the
following 30 years yeah
told me what to do and so but i wasn't
defined by it i was informed by my
idiocy
and so there's something that has to
happen when you go through a big
life-changing setback like that that you
have to reset your head to go forward
this is the ramsay show